pour la paix ils sont prêts à risquer
leur liberté sur la place rouge à moscou
ces russes bravent l'interdiction de
manifester et viennent courageusement
dire non à la guerre laissez moi laissez
moi les forces de l'ordre les interpelle
à tour de bras sans distinction hommes
femmes jeunes personnes âgées
pour le fourgon de police les
manifestants chantent la résistance
bonjour à tous nous sommes dans le car
de police à la sortie du métro les
policiers sont venus vers moi et m'ont
demandé mes papiers je ne les avais pas
ils montent à marcq
même ambiance ici à kaliningrad
j'ai survécu au siège de leningrad
mon père est mort au front qu'est ce que
vous voulez
partout dans le pays dans une
cinquantaine de villes des manifestants
viennent faire entendre la voix de cette
russie pacifiste certaines fois les
arrestations sont musclés les
manifestants passé à tabac et les
journalistes filmés la contestation
comme cet homme au bonnet sont molestés
ne me touchez pas je fais partie de la
presse je suis journaliste
inquisiteur ces policiers exige même de
fouiller dans les portables et de lire
les messages de ces jeunes
des artistes qui peignent aux couleurs
de l'ukraine cette mobilisation est sans
précédent alors on pourrait considérer
qu'on regarde de la population globale
de là où 630 millions personnes ces
quelques milliers de manifestants c'est
faible et c'est faux en réalité au
regard des risques terribles encourus
par des manifestants anti poutine quel
que soit d'ailleurs le sujet à aborder
ces ténors en russie d'autres voix
s'élèvent les pro guerre soutien à
vladimir poutine ont aussi défilé
ressortant même les drapeaux de l'union
soviétique